we talked to his manager alex cora he
said his fastball plays here as you look
at his numbers this postseason he really
earned that win in game three
of the division series with four shutout
innings and that extra inning win
brantley the second best average in the
american league this year hit 311.
strikes out good live fastball two of
the things to watch tonight first pitch
success has not been great coming into
tonight's game altuve brantley and
bregman a combined 5 for 36 in the alcs
fly ball into left
back at the wall this ball is gone
bregman sends one out and the astro
strike first in game four
well just what the doctor ordered and
they needed this badly needed to score
and they need to score a lot against
this team that is just waiting to get to
the plate in the boston red sox yeah for
zach cranky he's going to mix and match
he's going to change speeds you're going
to see a variance that is unlike any
other pitcher on the staff he's going to
try to work low throw a lot of breaking
balls and really try to mess up with the
timing of the hitters here's bogarts now
does not have an rbi here it is and
xander swings and drives wanga left high
and deep
it is long gone now to fenway park in
the lansdowne street 2-1 red sox
xander bogart with his third home run of
the post season and the red sox
gained the lead quickly and entered
touching them all a high towering blast
that was still going when it went over
the national car rental sign he's got
rbis now he does here he comes
that is what a play by bregman
sensational alex bregman holmard in the
top half of the first and in the bottom
half makes this play the runners advance
to second and third he's looking for a
big hit here he comes from pavetta
and maldonado flies to center easy for
[ __ ] hernandez
[Music]
off the end of the bat gonna be a tough
play guriel great play former third
baseman in cuba moves around really well
has become an outstanding first baseman
and to his right
had to slide made the stop popped up and
then fed the athlete that is zach grenky
for the out and yet again a starter for
the astros not able to get through three
full it's three games in a row now the
starter hasn't gotten through two here
it is
and a swing and a miss struck him out
what a big out picked up by brooks
rayleigh two down
the o2
is skied into right tucker near the line
and what a job by raley back to work is
the right-hander pavetta fifth inning
two to one first up chas mccormick
breaking ball got him looking strikeout
number three for pavetta now maldonado
2-2 pitch maldonado hits it in the air
to right
pretty well hit over to his left one
throw two out
here comes altuve
2-2 pitch
grounded to third debra circles it
gloves throws and
got him want to play on both ends
beautiful swipe at that one hop throw
and they get him denver is throwing him
out watch the right foot of schwarber
come off the bag when he received that
throw that bounced in the astros did not
challenge a terrific was nick pavetta
tonight as he goes five through 65
pitches in his first career postseason
sergeant gives way to the bullpen and
josh taylor here's a ground ball by
brantley right into the teeth of the
defense and the out at first here's an
0-1 from taylor and a high fly ball into
right
another
pop-up another out
two away and with correa coming up and i
believe adevino out in the bullpen
here comes a pitching change
one and two
here it is
strike three called fastball
see ya correa is gone what a job by out
of enough garrett takes over fourth
pitcher of the night for boston deals
with kyle tucker brings it and a fly
ball into center tucker got jammed a bit
[ __ ] hernandez one out
ground ball to bogarts
[Applause]
everybody's standing at fenway park two
and two
[Applause]
jose altuve who's old for three in this
game and all for his last 12.
pitch on the way
and altuve drills it deep to left field
and you can kiss it goodbye we're tied
at two jose altuve does it again
he tied game one with a two run homer
and he ties game four with a solo shot
over the monster seats that's 21
postseason homers now for al duve third
most all time ninth inning 2-2 game and
nathan evaldi takes over carlos
three four out of 15 in this lcs
fly ball into right pretty well hit
carrying at the wall
one hop and off the wall
correa will dig for second it's a lead
off double for houston and in right
field you got to hit this a long way
i'll tell you one thing i i think if he
gets out of the box thinking triple he
gets triple i agree and i don't think he
thought this ball was going to get over
the head
of renfro and ivaldi
it was a strikeout pitcher as i in one
here here's the 02.
and a big strikeout for ivaldi
still
[Applause]
and now jason castro the astros final
hope here in the top of the ninth
and that's lifted in the short right
center for a base hit correa around
third he will score curiel on his way to
third he's in safely jason castro comes
through and the astros lead it three to
two in the ninth and now with the bases
loaded after a walk to altuve here's
bradley and on the mound is martin perez
first pitch and brantley lines it toward
right center field that's down for a
base hit here comes guriel he scores
castro scores altuve around third coming
home he scores as well bradley clears
the bases with a three-run double and
the astros lead it six to two
alvarez one for three tonight a single
on a walk first pitch and jordan lifts
this one that gets down into shallow
left for a base hit grantly around third
and coming home the throw to play by
verdugo up the third base line brantley
slides in the head of vasquez's tag
alvarez with an rbi single it's seven to
two astros and they're headed for the
exits in boston
that's like a swinging bunt
gets away
one run will score that's bregman coming
to the plate alvarez will hold it third
and it's eight to two
gold guards trying to extend it pressly
trying to end it right now
for the one-two count pitch number 22.
he does
astros win at a final of nine to two and
they've evened his best of seven series
two games apiece
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes